you catch too much air if you get up
there and it's too windy and you catch
too much air you don't land where you're
supposed to land isn't that my gosh like
on the first jump that the video showed
I don't know if you guys could tell but
I went massive and I remember thinking
in the air like oh god please help me
land the wind obviously you can't see it
and I'm listening to music I have a lot
going on and you just kind of have to
like feel it but also like tress so I
like went as fast as I could and just
barely got my 720 around but you know
all of us had really terrible conditions
and I was just I wasn't extremely proud
of that run but when I came down and
seeing my family like freak out and my
dad was so excited I was just like all
right I'm gonna try to clean it up next
run like I had no idea that would stay I
thought for sure some of my girlfriends
would do their better run so like I
stayed in contest mode of like alright I
got to figure out that I wanted to do
back rodeo cab double nine front seven
and these mean nothing to me by the way
you could be saying it's absolutely they
sound like cowboy exactly yeah jumped up
forty does well we have a clip here of
you this is where you won the silver
medal on this is the big air where you
won silver and
[Applause]
the roughness is different from one one
and here comes our here
[Applause]
[Applause]
you talk about being you've said that
you connect with your top power will you
connect them to your cat power there was
a lion you're lying you're lying power
you identify with lions you think
there's a lion inside you oh there is my
boyfriend knows we - well I'm not always
peaceful and graceful and be a woman and
I just have a small Greek man in me yeah
[Laughter]
but yeah we're in a male-dominated sport
and like it takes a lot of power to get
out there and especially women we're
dealing with stuff all the time and my
friend Gabby's like she sent me a photo
of a black panther and that was like my
animal spirit last month and then when I
got to the Olympics I saw this really
beautiful photo of a lion and right
above it it said focus and I took a
photo put it on my background and I was
like that's gonna be my spirit vibe this
month like focus harness that inner lion
and I think that's the only way I landed
that trick because it's kind of funny
like cat instincts like my sister's
always called me a cat when I was little
because they do these tricks and be kind
of out of control and somehow get to my
feet that's very cool
that's very cool
you